six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our next caller
why don't we go to our two eight one
caller a caller from the two eight one
area code what's your name where you're
calling from and what's on your mind
today
uh hello my name is Jonathan and I'm
from Houston alright and I'm uh I'm
calling because a few days before
hurricane Harvey or at least the day
before
Rutina Harvey hit the coast there was on
social media and Facebook there was a
lot of posts about how it was going to
be a category three and then later on
that same day ABC 13 I remember it
specifically said that that was all fake
news and the hurricane was not going to
be that bad and as we all know it was
category four yeah so my question is I
guess at what point do you think it is
okay to lie to the public for their
safety well how were people safer by
being told category three was fake I
mean I guess I'm not sure I follow the
logic of it in other words did the local
ABC affiliate say it's not going to be
category three in order to make people
more scared or I'm not I'm just not
understanding well see the thing about
Houston it's very counterintuitive I
feel like a lot more than 30 people
would have died if we tried to evacuate
and any kind of panic about it being you
know the intensity that it would was
might have caused you know people to
flee oh they're saying maybe if it was
identified as category 4 from the
beginning then a lot of a lot more
people would have left and it might have
also caused evacuation orders and that
actually the evacuation itself might
have led to more deaths than the
hurricane led to yes kind of like when
with that previous hurricane I can't
remember its name where people drowned
in their cars because they were
evacuating but they would have been
safer in their homes well listen i don't
know the answer Jonathan in terms of
when is it okay to
lie to the masses for their own safety
because it's always as someone else
perceives is for their own safety
and it's not really the decision to make
always or it's not always the right
assessment that's made as to what is to
people safety I tend to be someone who
is favoring honesty and openness over
lying and deception and anytime you hear
the government's lying to you for your
own good I kind of resist that logic
although I understands particular
situations in which in which it might be
true so I unfortunately don't have a
straight answer for you although I think
it's better for the government not to
lie yes I can see why they did it but I
don't agree so you believe that there
was actually a concerted lie to keep
people there they believed it was going
to be category three and ended up being
category four I'm sorry well it's
possible that when it was announced as
category three that's truly what was
believed and then it's strengthened
right it is possible that that wasn't a
lie yes but they said that ABC 13 they
came out on Facebook on a post and said
that it was not going to be as bad as it
was being stated okay well that I
couldn't comment on that I don't know
what ABC 13 did or didn't do but
interesting question Jonathan appreciate
it a lot to think about quite a quite a
thought exercise I think is what we
could call it